cuáles son las críticas específicas que
hace la oposición en cuanto a la gestión
del gobierno durante esta pandemia
sí muy buenos días pues como usted bien
lo decía la lentitud de la toma de
decisiones muchos consideran que el
gobierno habría podido tomar estas
medidas hace un mes hace un mes y medio
justamente cuando los epidemiólogos
habían advertido en bajar con base en
los modelos que tenían de esta epidemia
pues que precisamente la variante
británica se iba a regar por todo el
país que iba a convertirse en dominante
y que se iba a volver a tener un pico de
contagios y por eso habían sugerido
pedido al gobierno que tomara medidas
radicales como éstas que tomaron de un
nuevo confinamiento pero no fue así el
gobierno le dio largas a este asunto en
aras de una mayor libertad para los
ciudadanos la otra crítica es también en
cómo se maneja y cómo se toman las
decisiones porque el gobierno toma las
decisiones entre sí entre sus expertos
el gabinete pero no tienen en cuenta las
voces de las diferentes bancadas no es
un verdadero debate el que se vivió aquí
a pesar de que se acaba de aprobar estas
medidas por amplia mayoría ahora natalia
dentro de este plan de medidas para
frenar esta pandemia son muchas además
del confinamiento por el meses del
cierre de las escuelas como
a las personas para conocer todo este
plan y poder organizar su vida en torno
a todas estas restricciones
así después ese es uno de los
rompecabezas y algo con lo que las
personas tienen que jugar rápidamente de
cómo van a organizarse para el mes de
abril por una parte porque tienen a los
niños en casa durante todo ese mes sin
embargo todavía les queda una semana de
clases que va a ser a distancia que es
la próxima semana y al mismo tiempo los
papás van a tener que trabajar también
en casa todos aquellos que puedan el
problema va a estar para aquellas
familias que no tienen con quién dejar a
los niños y que no tienen un trabajo que
les permita precisamente trabajar en
remoto así que esta va a ser uno de los
problemas y pues muchos han también ha
anulado cancelado ya sus planes de
vacaciones dentro de las próximas tres
semanas